it's great to be joined on the program
today by Professor Asha Auerbach who is
professor of physics at Technion in
Israel and has also written a graphic
novel max the demon versus entropy of
Doom which explains the generally
complex concepts of entropy and the
second law of thermodynamics in terms
that we can all hopefully understand
it's so great to talk to you let's let's
sort of start at the very beginning the
the concept of entropy I have read what
I would consider to be a fair amount for
a layperson about the concept and it's
still quite difficult for me to sort of
explain it to someone else which i think
is sometimes a good way to explore
whether one actually understands
something can they explain it to
somebody else
so how can we start thinking about the
concept of entropy
well entropy is a tricky subject to
explain and it's something that is
taught only at high level courses in
universities there's a huge barrier for
explaining entropy to most students
which is the math that you need to know
the multivariate calculus some
statistics and so on but it's a very
important concept and one that governs
essentially the energy flow and it tells
us you know how energy will flow from
hot to cold from low entropy systems to
high entropy system and it tells us
about why pollution always grows it's a
concept that is very crucial for
understanding a lot of the problems
facing our world actually looking at
global warming and other energy crisis
water pollution and so on so now that I
said it's an important concept and it's
a tricky one to explain I think that
there are actually certain ideas that
people connect to that can give a long
way towards understanding entropy and
that's the relation between order and
disorder a system that is ordered
naturally becomes disordered under time
we know that from daily experience
and entropy is in a sense measuring the
amount of disorder in a system but one
has to define what you mean by order and
disorder but it's something that
intuitively a lot of people connect to
so we thought that in this comic book we
can actually make it more accessible
make entropy more accessible to
laypeople without going through the math
by connecting to the ideas of disorder
so maybe let's do a couple of examples
if we can when we think about the
concepts of of order and disorder can
you give us one example of how over time
we would naturally expect to see more
disorder right well we have experienced
that you know when you let a kid loose
in a room and the all the toys are
ordered on the shelf after a while all
the toys are scattered around without
any particular order and that's
something that happens naturally and if
you keep on waiting it won't order
itself now that's a an example from a
human behavior but it also happens when
you mix milk in the tape I mean you just
put the milk at one particular point in
the tea and after a while the milk is
spread all around so the position of the
milk molecules become highly spread out
and less ordered that's an interesting
one because and I think that that's a
good one because sometimes I some of the
most effective examples that I've read
about how to understand the concept of
entropy are those which explore that you
could not possibly go backwards in some
of with some of these examples in other
words once you imagine putting milk into
tea you initially see sort of a division
between the milk and the tea and whether
or not you start stirring to sort of
homogenized that mixture of milk and tea
there's really no way to undo that
process there's no way to separate the
milk from the tea back out and for me
that's been a crucial aspect of
understanding this concept right this is
a demonstration I wouldn't call it
understanding from the physicists point
of view because you just look at the
phenomena and say oh I recognize this so
that's a good
station of entropy increasing over time
and not decreasing the reasons for that
are actually quite deep and it took a
long time until physicists actually
understood the reasons for disorder
always to grow that's called the second
law of thermodynamics for a long time
the second law was actually an axiom was
another postulate that you added to the
classical mechanics we all know Newton
but much later it was understood that
this is actually a natural course of
events when you have many many particles
in the system when you have lots and
lots of particle degrees of freedom the
chaotic motion of particles which
interact with each other leads to the
increase of entropy and to the second
law of thermodynamics now
the comic book that we wrote was about
the imaginary creature that Maxwell
the famous physicist that invented
electromagnetism thought about as a way
of disputing the second law he said
there could be a creature essentially
like our ourselves that would put order
in things and you won't have to spend
any energy doing that you will just have
to open and shut the door and order
things separate hi separate the gases
between two different compartments into
a high pressure and low pressure or a
hot and a cold or reverse essentially
the arrow of time by just observing the
different particles and allowing and
disallowing them to move in certain ways
and that was a puzzle that was a paradox
that kept businesses busy for more than
60 years or 70 years until it was
understood that such a creature cannot
exist and therefore the second law of
thermodynamics was said this is actually
the topic that is explained in in our
book it's it's the fact that a Maxwell
demon is a demon is is not something
that we can design let's say nowadays
with robots and nano electronics it's a
impossibility in physics
and it's a quite tricky subject to to
understand and why is it important to
the sort of day-to-day lives of humans
in other words conceptually we may or
may not understand entropy and the
second law of thermodynamics but in what
ways does this impact our lives well the
second law impacts our life immensely
the fact that we can only get useful
energy from low entropy sources which is
fuel sunlight and so on and we can't use
all the immense amount of energy that we
have in just tap water just on the heat
of the temperature of the oceans we
can't use that energy this is a
consequence of the second law and when
we want to understand how where we could
get energy that we could use from and
where we cannot we have to know the
second law so this is why it's important
for our daily lives it also tells us
that what we have to concentrate on is
not the energy but the lower entropy so
it focuses discussions on the right
topic and most I think most people in
the public are not really aware of the
importance of understanding entropy so
this is connected to our you know our
problems of energy and pollution but
conceptually I think it's important to
understand that the laws of nature have
this natural increase of disorder it's a
something that is one of the most
fundamental laws that even Albert
Einstein claimed he believes that this
is the one law that will never be proven
incorrect so it's a it's it's a very
important laws in physics and
engineering and as I said it's a it's a
bit tricky to explain why this law
exists in the face of ideas like Maxwell
demon or mechanized Maxwell demon that
people have tried to create and faith so
that's
motivation yeah I encourage the audience
to check out the graphic novel max the
demon versus entropy of doom we've been
speaking with aza
Auerbach who is professor of physics at
Technion in Israel so great to speak to
you today well thank you very much